One aim of Rethink Rubbish, is to see a lot
less stuff going in here
which all goes to landfill.
When you do need to get rid of rubbish, here’s
what you need to know and the same rules apply
for both bins and official Council rubbish
bags.
We can’t take hazardous or toxic waste,
this includes stuff like engine oil and leftover paint.
These should be taken to the Southbrook Resource
Recovery Park and disposed of properly
it’s usually free.
We also can’t take explosives or ammunition,
ring your local police station for advice
when dealing with these.
Broken glass or china should be well wrapped
with newspaper.
And make sure ashes are completely cold before putting them in your bin or bag.
To learn more or to sign up for collection
reminders visit waimakariri.govt.nz/rethinkrubbish